الى تركيا حيث اعلنت المعارضه قبل قليل عن
مرشحها للرئاسه فقد اعلن زعيم حزب السعاده
التركي ان الاحزاب المشاركه في تحالف
الشعب او ما يسمى بالطاوله السداسيه ترشح
زعيمه حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله وعاقب اعلاني
اسمه مرشحا للمعارضه قال كاليجدار اوبلو
ان احزاب الطاوله السداسيه ستقود تركيا
بالمشوره والتفاهم عبر ما سماه بالنظام
البرلماني المعزز مضيفا ان زعماء الاحزاب
السته سيعملون بصفتهم مساعدين لرئيس
الجمهوريه ويشارك في الطاوله السداسيه او
ما يسمى بتحالف الشعب زعماء حزب الشعب
الجمهوري والحزب الجيد وحزب السعاده
والحزب الديمقراطي وحزب المستقبل وحزب
التقدم او حزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم
معنى الانا من انقر مراسل الجزيره معتز
بالله حسن ما الذي نعرفه عن مرشح المعارضه
الذي اعلنت اسمه قبل قليل اوريك داير
اوبلو معتز بالله حسن
يعني عن سياساته
وهو زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري ابرز احزاب
المعارضه وهو الحزب الابرز الابرز والحزب
الذي اسسه مؤسس الجمهوريه التركيه مصطفى
كمال اتاتورك بعد تاسيس الجمهوريه في عام
1923 كما الكريستال اوغلو وصل الى رئاسه
هذا الحزب في عام 2010 وذلك خلفا لدينيز
بايكال
رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمالك هو الخصم
السياسي الاد للرئيس التركي الحالي او
واحد من ابرز الخصومه السياسيين للرئيس
التركي الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان قاد قاده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري وحزب العداله والتنميه
تسعه انتخابات توجد متنوعه توجد بفوز حزب
العداله والتنميه طبعا هذا هو كمال
رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري اليوم اعلان
الطاوله السداسيه او ما يعرف في تحالف
الشعب لكمال دار اوغلو ياتي بعد مسيره
طويله من الاجتماعات خلال الشهور الماضيه
كان هناك انتقادات كثيره لما اصطلح على
تسميتها الطاوله السداسيه وذلك لانها تضم
قاده سته احزاب معارضه ابرز سته احزاب
معارضه كان هناك انتقادات لهذه الطاوله
لتاخرها في اعلان المرشح حتى ان كثيرا من
السياسيين الموالين الرئيس اردوغان كانوا
يتحدثون عن انه بعد الانتخابات ستعلن هذه
الطاوله ولكن اعلنت هذه الطاوله السداسيه
اليوم عن ان مرشحها هو كمال كان هناك كما
نذكر يوم الجمعه الماضي كان هناك ربما يصح
ان نصفه بالمطاب الذي تعرضت له هذه
الطاوله عندما نهضت عنها رئيسه الحزب
الجيد ميرال اكشنير وقلت اروق هذه الطاوله
وقالت انها لم تعد تمثل اراده الشعب كانت
وقتها تشير الى انها لا تقبل ان يتم ترشيح
كمال كليتش دار اوغلوها تريد ان يتم اجراء
استطاعات رايي وان هذه الاستطلاعات تشير
الى ان منصوريه واكرم امام اوغلو رئيس
بلديه انقره واسطنبول هم الاول ولكن يبدو
ان هناك توافقا تم اليوم وبالتالي تم
الاعلان عن كمالك
المرشحه المشترك للطاوله السداسيه او ما
يعرف بتحالف الشعب شكرا
معنا من انقره